sur les pistes de solution de
Davide Gentile.
- Ils partagent leur vie
et ont aussi un gros problème
en commun. Diane et Richard
sont des patients orphelins :
leur médecin de famille
est parti à retraite.RICHARD DAn
- Ça fait deux ans, deux
qu'on est... qu'on cherche.
Et là, on est sur une liste qui
est supposée... dans quatre ans
qu'on va en avoir, alors...
- Faute de médecin,
ils sont pris en charge
par une infirmière.
- Depuis la dernière fois qu'on
s'est vus, est-ce qu'il y a eu
des changements au niveau
de la santé?
- Véronique Gagnon est l'une des
trois infirmières de la Clinique
d'accès intégré de Magog.
NADIA FORTIN, infirmière,
Clinique d'accès intégrée, Magog
- Donc, j'ai le droit de vous
prescrire un bilan sanguin, tel
que vous le désirez. Et aussi,
de vous rencontrer pour faire
la cytologie dans le but
de faire le dépistage pour
le cancer de l'utérus.
- Elles prescrivent des examens
de dépistage et font des suivis
de maladie chronique.
VÉRONIQUE GAGNON, infirmière,
Clinique d'accès intégrée,
- Il y a le diabète, il y a la
haute pression, il y a le taux
de cholestérol plus élevé.
- Une autonomie déléguée
par les médecins dn.
Dre JOHANNE DESFORGES, coordo.,
Guichet accès médecin de famille
- C'est la beauté de la chose.
nt autonomes. Alors,
autonomes, et elles n'ont pas
besoin d'approbation médicale
pour poser ces gestes-là.
- Vous allez pouvoirdéposer vot.
- Richard et Diane
sont satisfaits.
- Moi, jue c'est
un bon compromis. Même, en fait,
en ce moment, j'ai pas besoin
de médecin, là.
- Heureusement pour lui parce
que l'Estrie a de moins en moins
de médecins de famille.
Dre STÉPHANIE BLAIS-BOILARD,
Départ. rég. médecine générale
- Ça fait plus de dix ans qu'on
a beaucoup plus de départs
à la retraite et de médecins
qui quittent la première ligne
aussi, que d'arrivées
de nouveaux médecins.
Donc, à chaque année, il y a
un écart qui se creuse.
- Ce qui fait que la proportion
d'Estriens qui ont un médecin
de famille a baissé.
En 2018, 86 % de la population
était inscrite auprès
d'un médecin. Ça a baissé
à 82 % l'an dernier.
Déléguer des responsabilités
aux infirmières devient
carrément incontournable.
Dr MARC-ANDRÉ AMYOT, président,
Féd. médecins omnipraticiens, Qc
- Avec une pénurie de 1000
médecins de famille au québec,
on peut plus assurer seuls
l'entièreté des besoins
de la population. Ces besoins-là
doivent être répartis
sur d'autres professionnels.
CHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre Santé
et Services sociaux, Québec
- La prise en charge, pour moi,
ne doit plus être maintenant
la question d'un médecin,
mais elle doit être la question
de plusieurs personnes.
- En Estrie, médecins et
infirmières travaillent déjà
main dans la main.
- Peut-être juste vérifier
si la personne a des symptômes
de thyroide.
- Mais les médecins gardent
un rôle conseil.
- Si la situation devient
encore plus complexe, alors, là,
il y a un médecin répondant qui
peut répondre à la situation.
- Seuls les cas plus complexes
sont référés à un médecin
dans cette clinique.
Dre CAROLINE LANGLAIS, médecin
de famille, Clinique méd. du Lac
- Quand ils viennent chez nous,
c'est vraiment parce que, bien,
ils avaient vraiment besoin
de voir un médecin et on a pas
trouvé d'autre professionnel
qui pouvait répondre
à leur besoin.
- Et environ 30 % des patients
vus ici par la Dr Caroline
Langlais n'ont pas de médecin
de famille.
- Are you coughing?
- C'est le cas de Robert Scott,
tout juste arrivé de Toronto,
où il n'avait pas non plus
de médecin de famille.
"Avec ce système, c'est moins
dérangeant de ne pas être
inscrit auprès d'un médecin,"
dit-il. Ce nouveau Québécois
est enchanté par l'efficacité
du système implanté en Estrie.
"C'est bien mieux qu'à
Toronto," dit M.Scott, parce que
l'accès à des soins est
un problème pan-canadien.
Avec le vieillissement rapide
de la population, la solution
ne peut plus passer uniquement
par les médecins.
Ici Davide Gentile,
Radio-Canada, Magog.